let's go over that example that I gave
in the last video where I'm in this
village and I start a bank to to kind of
match up savers with investment
opportunities and I actually want to do
it one to two hit the point home a
little bit more about how a bank makes
money and I actually think this example
is a very good instrument to actually
teach you about a new financial
statement that we really haven't I don't
think I've covered it all much and
that's the income statement so far
you're familiar with balance sheets
hopefully and now we'll learn what an
income statement is so let's say that
this is my balance sheet at the
beginning of my first year of operation
at the beginning of year one and let's
see let me see if I can recreate it I
think I had said that I had originally
capitalized this company with a million
dollars that was coming from my savings
or maybe I went to ten of my friends and
they gave me a hundred thousand each but
we don't care about how that equity was
raised all we know is that we had a
million dollars and then I had BOTS
bought a building that I could put money
in that looks really safe and people
would feel secure giving that money
putting that money into that building so
let's say I had a million dollars of
real estate 1 million of real estate and
then the rest of the village saw this
nice big fortress I had constructed and
so they gave me at least part of their
savings as deposits saying that wow
that's a safer place to put my money
than in my mattress or buried it under
in my backyard and you know this Bank of
Sal says that he's going to give me some
interest and he seems to be a fairly
reputable fellow in our village so let's
let's let's deposit some of our savings
with him so I get 10 million dollars of
deposits and of course I told them that
look this isn't alone although it kind
of is I'm not borrowing this money from
you you guys can use this money whenever
you need it and and because of that I
need to set some of this deposits aside
in case someone comes the next day and
says though you know I gave you that
dollar yesterday I actually need that
dollar now too
I don't know pay pay for my my my teeth
cleaning or something so I need to set
aside some of it and I figure well as if
I set aside 10% of it that's the most
that anyone would ever come in one day
unless there's some type of strange run
on the bank so I'm going to set aside
10% of it
as reserves so it's cash reserves so
let's say 1 million dollars of cash 1
million dollars of cash if I thought for
some reason that there's a higher
likelihood of all everyone coming at
once for their money or a large
percentage of the people coming at once
I'd want larger reserves and then
finally I'm left with what 9 million
dollars right the gave me 10 I put one
aside I'm left with 9 million dollars to
loan out to this is productive capital
and when I say capital that's just a a
claim on someone's goods and services
that can be used to construct or perform
something that adds value that that
creates more value than was used so
that's 9 million of loans and I know I
always keep talking in those terms and I
do that because I think in our in our
society today we get we get so fixated
with the points and that's money or the
dollar bills that we often forget what
the points represent the points or the
money represents claims on goods and
services I've actually you know I've met
people who become obsessed with well
actually you know like on Khan Academy I
get emails from people who want to get
extra points on their account and
they're obsessed with it and it's just a
number but what's important is what does
a point system really do for you and in
money those points represent future
claims on goods and services but anyway
so this is how my balance sheet looked
at the beginning of year 1 and I said
well I'm going to be getting in 10% on
these loans and let's say that I I'm
very good and none of them default and I
really do get my 10% and I said that I'm
going to pay these people out to 5%
right so what happens over the course of
that year so how much interest income am
I going to get interest income interest
income let's call that interest in tink
interest income so 9 million times 10
percent I'm going to get $900,000
$900,000 and then what's my interest
expense
I probably should've done this in green
but I think it's my interest expense
interest expense well I had to I have to
pay out 5% on the 10 million so it's
$500,000 I'll put it as a negative
number just you know it's an expense so
since I said it's an expense you might
want to put as a positive number but
that's just an accounting convention but
I think you get the idea let me put it
as minus $500,000 and then to operate
this Bank this bet you know I had this
building it had to be cleaned it has to
be maintained I had to hire bank tellers
and security guards and I had to buy my
security guards machine guns so I have
expenses above and beyond just this
little interest transaction that's going
on so let's say that I have salaries so
I have some other expenses salaries
let's say I have to pay I don't know
let's say it's - 50k a year in salaries
that I have to pay and let's say upkeep
of the building you have to paint it
every now and then upkeep upkeep I have
to install new marble tiles every now
and then to make because I have to
project this impression of the shining
impenetrable fortress so upkeep is
actually a big expense of me so I spend
50k on
upkeep and so what am I left with
see 900 minus 500 is 400 minus another
hundred so I'm left with 300 thousand
but even though this is a primitive
village that I live in it's not so
primitive that it does not have taxes
and so this is my pre-tax income my cell
phone is ringing but I'll ignore it it's
very hard to ignore but anyway this is
my pre-tax income but my local village
government says no well you know you
have to pay for the army and all of the
other services that we provide so they
take 30% so income taxes income tax
income tax they take let's say say they
take one-third so they take
okay and so what am I going to be left
with what is my net income net income
300 - 100 I'm left with 200k fair enough
and just so you know this is the income
statement and I'm going to talk a little
bit about how all of these match up so
let me let me draw a big nice box around
it just so it looks like a proper
statement of something so what is my
balance sheet going to look like at the
end of the year at the end of the year
given that this is how much money I made
well say those loans they haven't been
paid off just people paid the 10%
interest on them so I still have those
loans on my balance sheet let me draw
the loan so if I still have nine million
dollars of assets which are those loans
then paid them off I still have I still
have the building and actually since I
spent 50,000 on upkeep all of the wear
and tear was kind of made up for with my
upkeep so it's still worth a million
dollars so I still have a million dollar
building nine million of loans
outstanding I had a million dollars of
cash and now how much cash do I have
well I had that million dollars before
and I'm assuming that my overall level
of deposits do not change over the
course of the year so I had a million
dollars of cash and nothing dramatic
happens with the deposits million
dollars of cash over the course of the
year I show right here I made $200,000
and this two hundred thousand is
essentially going to be cash now so now
I have 1.2 million of cash 1.2 million
of cash my deposits haven't changed I
still have 10 million of deposits I
still have 10 million of deposits those
are liabilities because I owe them to
the people who've deposited their money
with me I owe them money and so what am
I left with what is my equity my equity
was 1 million what is my equity now well
equity is just total assets minus total
liability so what are my total assets
now 9 plus 1 is 10 plus 1.2 I have 11
point 2 million of total assets minus my
total liabilities minus
so I have 1.2 million now of equity 1.2
million of equity now something
interesting has happened what has been
my change in equity I had 1 million
dollars of equity now I have 1.2 million
dollars of equity so my change in equity
so 1 million to 1.2 million dollars
so we could call it if you're used to
the math notation you could use that
Delta notation triangle just means
change my change in equity is equal to
$200,000 and that is the same thing as
your net income so what is an income
statement well first of all this is an
income statement but how does it connect
with the balance sheet and later we'll
talk about the cash flow statement well
an income a balance sheet is just a
snapshot of what you have and what you
owe at any given point in time this is
the balance sheet at the beginning of
the year this is the balance sheet at
the end of year this is a snapshot of
what you have and what you owe at the
beginning this is a snapshot of what you
have and what you owe at the end of the
year the income statement tells you what
happened over the course of this year so
it essentially tells you how did you get
from this balance sheet to this balance
sheet and another way to think about the
income statement at the end it'll tell
you all of your inputs what money came
in what Connie came out in the form of
expenses and taxes etc and then you had
a net income number and that net income
number is actually the change in equity
so if you have a positive net income in
a year the balance sheets equity will
increase by that amount in a year and if
you had a negative net income your
balance sheets equity will decrease in a
year so you could view you could
actually call your net income is the
same thing as your change in equity and
another thing you want to talk about
what what's your return on equity well
your initial equity was 1 million
dollars how much money did we make well
the it grew by $200,000 so 200,000 over
1 million
well you know we could think we could
call that 1000 thousands that equals a
20% that was our return on equity right
we we put in a million and we got 20%
more than that that was our return on
equity equals roee I notice the return
on equity is really that's the same
thing that's change of equity divided by
starting equity which is the same thing
as net income in the period net income
divided by starting equity and we well
I'm defining it as starting equity
sometimes people talk it is river
average equity and all of that but
anyway I thought that this was a good
tool to at least introduce you to the
notion of an income statement and show
you how it all connects because that's
the that's kind of the beauty of
accounting is that you have these these
different financial statements that are
actually very intertwined with each
other you give me two balance sheets and
then I can actually construct the income
statement that must have happened in
between them anyway see you in the next
video